beating a nation last month's oslo
esports cup beating him a couple of
times in vikings a dutch championships
uh if anything yeah uh jordan is in in
anisha's head and he actually told me
that when i was doing the interview with
him during the masters he said that i
never beat jordan so forget about it he
beats me every time do really yeah we're
gonna get started here instead it's uh
an opening david it is and it's the reti
opening actually one that we focused a
lot on yesterday one of my favorite
first moves white bringing out the night
um and the retti the beauty of it is
that white is super flexible now white
can choose which pawn to push is jordan
gonna push
okay this is maybe the third or fourth
uh most popular option in that position
um if that pushing the b pawn forward
getting ready to create a nice little
home for white's dark square bishop now
white dark bishop is going to park
itself on the b2 square and fiance
itself on the longest diagonal yeah this
is it's interesting because when you see
jordan play and uh you see anish is
going the other way fee and shattering
but
he often tries to get niche out of the
main live theory because we know how
strong anisha is in main line double fee
and chateau's system here david that is
quite peculiar isn't it it's not just
peculiar but it's very unlike jordan and
normally he's quite direct and part of
the reason he's the core kind of member
of magnus carlsen's team and
previously part of anish geary's team is
because he's so good at these attacking
ideas where you calculate everything and
this is the type of position where
is b5 respect i was gonna say is it
called the speckled hen speckled head is
that right i i remember keef alcohol
some openings have got ridiculous names
like uh the monkey's bum is there is one
um
i didn't just make up i think but this
might be called the speckled hen i don't
know if it's named after a beer in
england or something else is that right
speckled egg it might be a spoken egg
but i think it's very similar to this i
think it's normally a slightly different
variant but it's definitely pushing
pushing that black blue pawn forward and
uh simon you mentioned those weird wacky
opening names
yeah stay tuned later in the week i did
do a test with magnus on some weird
wacky opening names and uh did you know
them all
okay he knew some of them and uh there
are a lot of cool opening games i think
there's over 1 500
named openings out there so that's a lot
i don't know how many you guys can name
i couldn't have named this one for sure
well i just got this wrong
was it the egg or the hen which came
first
the reason this is such a kind of weird
opening is because now black gains so
much time blacks pawn uh and gaining so
much space as well black's pawns on this
left flank throwing themselves forward
and it's this is so strange you know
that there are only two games in my
database and
yeah wow and uh we're talking about
database of millions and millions of
games and uh
it's it's bizarre you know i
didn't guess any of those moves actually
because i actually expected and we
talked a lot about this kind of whole
concept of uh pawns dominating the night
circuits but anish has just taken that
rule and just thrown out the window and
it's like yeah i'm gonna step forward
attack the night we can expect a chess
ball course on this so you can't be now
on the speckled uh i don't know which
one it is speckled something um
yeah the egg or the hen maybe both but
your 29th chest of course oh yeah
yeah i mean i've seen peter fiddler play
this way as well actually in torment in
ireland the bombardier tournament well i
think everyone's favorite tournament
once you go there you always want to go
back but
this is this is more jordan this is this
is more his style isn't it this is
really aggressive from jordan and we
have to jump in and show what's just
happened because with this last move
white pushing the pawn to the e4 square
better late than never um he has set a
small trap this pawn is untouchable it
looks like it's undefended but if you
take it with the black knight then
suddenly you've opened up this diagonal
for the white bishop and um suddenly the
white bishop can actually go and take
its counterpart on the g7 square this
bishop was undefended and white wins a
piece so uh this pawn you cannot touch
it and big question for any giri if you
just castle which is a very safe logical
move then you have to decide what to do
after white pushes even further forward
i'm taking away the knight we know
what's coming after that but maybe don't
we once the black knight moves away once
it vacates the king side the protection
of black's king then suddenly as simon
mentions we know what's coming the h1 is
going to throw itself down the board oh
yeah oh yeah baby this is the target the
black kick
that is a red rag to an h pawn isn't it
that one so i mean we're not saying it's
good for white it probably isn't but but
uh it's fun it's a lot of fun for us
it's the jordan thing to do isn't it it
certainly is and um i remember anish
actually one thing about maybe worth
pointing out he wrote about one of his
games in ewing chess uh which is a
really good publication and he was
talking about the fianchetto bishops
and he pointed out which i i think is
just something really worth remembering
that the fiancee bishop on the king side
so if we see the ones on the right hand
side of the board where where they're
both finnshattoed are better than the
ones on the other side of the board
because you can guard that bishop with
your king later on and i always find
that you know if you've got two bishops
have you as you have pointing at each
other the one that's guarded by the king
when it goes to castle is the better
bishop because it's more secure and it's
just something worth thinking about if
if you're trying to uh uh develop you
know fianchetto sometimes that that
little uh that little point that's
interesting i've never ever heard that
rule before so um a bit of nugget a bit
of nugget of information there from
geary and uh that must mean he quite
likes his position if the black king
does castle and guard the bishop in
front of it but
he's hesitating maybe just the ghosts of
all those defeats to jordan in the past
uh just saying okay don't castle the
black king don't make it a target for
white's attack
uh maybe black would just push a pawn
maybe to stop the advance of white
central porn
it's already getting exciting i was
going to ask i mean do you think that
this opening is so random and so offbeat
that anish will be looking at
really trying to neutralize it because
there's kind of we spoke to spoke about
this a few days earlier about how you
know when your opponent plays something
weird
it's kind of annoying he's castled
he's going i think the problem with this
opening is how do you neutralize it all
the pawns or the pieces are still on the
board and okay come on harry we're
following inspiration we just showed is
it going to go okay hands in the air
like you just don't care oh what he's
got he's gone okay okay it's gone in the
middle oh okay strange decision of where
to put the black knight it looks like
the black knight is about to get trapped
behind enemy lines in white half of the
board but maybe that black knight does
have a couple of escape squares to uh to
run to
yeah interesting this is already one of
the weirdest
positions i've seen
in uh in terms of openings uh on the
tour this season and it's only moved
nine uh okay white does finally complete
the fianceto of his light squad bishop
and black trying to break out fighting
for space in the center now yeah this is
a nice move i think that anish has just
played because uh he was getting a
little bit cramped in the center of the
board and you you can't let your
opponent take all the space in the
center and this last lunge at least is
trying to grab uh some of that space
back from the black side big question
now guys uh are we gonna see on passant
black's pawn has just moved two squares
forward white can just capture that pawn
as if it's moved one square
so do you take this pawn off the board
do you take with your own pawn or do you
leave it if you leave this pawn on the
board then you have to step back with
your own knight and
maybe suddenly these nights are a bit
clumsy uh black's knight actually looks
like it's uh the better piece if
anything but if you take on passant then
suddenly there is tension between these
two bishops we could for example see a
trade and black's queen taking this pawn
black's porn recapturing and
still big question this night fee and
keto knights are the worst pieces uh
unless they're defending a king
so yeah strange uh strange position but
big decision for you yeah we talked
about on pass on uh yesterday actually
um with kyo and we mentioned it's one of
the hardest one of the hardest moves to
to to grasp when you're trying to learn
chess because you're taking but not on a
square where there's a piece you know i
think loads of people struggle this i
remember myself i was like you can't do
that it took me ages to try to get used
to this rule so it's it's a strange one
capturing passing yeah and then it only
happens to reinforce this it only
happens when your pawn is on the fifth
rank and your opponent tries to bypass
it by moving two squares forward so your
opponent's pawn has to move two squares
forward um if it had just for example
moved uh one square forward now then you
can't take it your opponent's pawn has
to have moved two squares
but jordan he says no he doesn't want to
take this pawn and he steps back with
his knight this is much more of a jordan
type of decision keeping the tension
keeping pieces on the board but
as i mentioned these two white knights
somehow they don't feel like they're
that great anymore there's nowhere for
them to jump to later yeah black's
position kind of suddenly looks
harmonious doesn't it you know he's got
the center he's got yeah he's gained
more space you know his pieces he's got
natural posts so
i like
anish's position i think he needed to
capture that pawn
yeah but better style isn't it what
happens now for example if black's
bishop does come out stopping white from
castling because now white can't castle
through check um that's not legal uh so
now white's king is stranded in the
center of the board if you try and block
this bishop's diagonal for example
pushing your pawn forward then the black
knight might be able to jump in
yes we could see a trade for example but
now white has lost all control over the
dark squares
really
really in balanced position and
anish has been thinking for a long time
but uh
okay he does push his pawn forward
gaining more space very logical as well
um yeah i think this is just jordan
trying to play against the man not the
board
he's trying to get inside anish's head
yet again
and make it as imbalanced as possible
yeah that does remind me of that um
those uh tweets from yesterday's quiz of
the day where they say they try to play
something creative and then spend their
time going why why did i do this
why did i create create my own problems
and
talking about tweets while the players
are thinking you know we're asking what
is your chess level and amin char
rivarvi says that
they're at the level that they can
surprise and win against a 2200 rated
player which is a very strong level
and then immediately fall for a scholars
mate the next game oh
what kind of level is that
very inconsistent inconsistent how did
you keep yourself guessing yeah and i'm
guessing
yeah and obi-wan martin says that their
chest level is foundation everyone
everyone else is using me to build their
chest careers trying to improve on only
chess by playing about 20 games every
day and studying like crazy
yeah
it's definitely that is the way to go if
you want to improve your chest and just
keep playing chess and there's lots of
resources out there like for instance
chessable chess 24 and
many many more if you're at the very
very novice level the the beginner level
do you recommend playing more or reading
more
both actually yeah i mean you there's
such a wonder about being at the
foundation level about being a beginner
because everything is new to you and uh
you know there's a delight that you get
when you discover something that you
know you think oh eureka i got it and
when you win your first game
there is nothing
bigger actually than winning that game i
i mean you get a real adrenaline rush i
don't think you ever get that again
it's it's this
television broadcast is creating a
really weird special specimen of chess
players sometimes because you have
players who's hardly ever played a game
and they still have some tactical
dispositions and some understanding that
they received from listening to a lot of
players like you yeah and often they
have that understanding but putting that
into practice is the hardest thing so i
would definitely recommend playing for a
period playing a bunch of games but then
mixing it up and then going through a
study phase back to playing studying and
then just that kind of freshness will
help
improve meanwhile a couple of moves
white did castle the king very logical
white's king super safe but uh after the
black knight came out white's rook
centralizing it does feel like white's
pawn in the centre of the board is a
target definitely simon uh do you think
this game is maybe turning in anisha's
favor
yeah i do i i think uh we're very
surprised about anisha's night jump you
see the knight that's in white's half of
the board but this move i think which
she played instantaneously has turned
out to be i think a great move a
fantastic move because it's allowed the
black pawn to come into the center of
the board so that that to me was a key
move showing great understanding by
niche and i mean talking about learning
as well you know this is the chesapeal
leg
and chessboard is such a good resource
if you want to learn openings you might
not find this opening because it's a
little bit wacky but if you're trying to
get some basic opening knowledge they've
got loads of free stuff out there as
well so you know loads of free courses
so you can start with that you don't
have to get your wallet out to start
with but then if you want to get the
real uh professional tuition then
there's there's nearly a course and
everything out there and these short and
sweet courses that you're referring to
they're amazing because you can actually
still use their move trainer and that's
such a lovely way to learn chess i mean
actually i only used um wesley so's
short and sweet course and i just used
it to kind of like build myself a
repertoire by pushing the kingspawn and
uh it was fantastic yeah i was wondering
i know uh our main presenter today he's
a poker star and you know it comes from
a poker background while i knock over
all the drinks behind me
but do you have something similar in
poker do you have i know it's a
different game but do you have any ways
you you sort of have to repeat patterns
to learn in that
or is it quite unique to chess
it's i think it's a lot of aspects that
are quite similar i think from my
understanding a lot of poker players
who's later started chess they they tend
to have a pretty good understanding of
a lot of middle game type situations but
they may not have discipline that it
takes to really
try to get into the more learned part of
chess they have a lot of the intuitive
stuff and they never get there because
myself included because it's so hard to
to accept the fact that you're not going
to be instinctive about this you haven't
learned it at a young enough age
and and you can't bring it to the level
that you like to because both are mind
games it's quite similar yet so
different that you can never never push
that threshold in a sense yeah it's i
mean we all started very young i mean
very very young and i think uh you can
you can there are cases of people
learning you know when they're later on
in life but you've got to put a lot of
hours in you know and it gets harder
when you have a family and the life
outside of uh chess so but i mean even
as long as you're improving i think
that's that's the key thing isn't it and
enjoying it
it's changed so much in the last 10
years alone with all the technology
all the new developments ways of
learning is it the same in poker um i
mean just the amount of exposure the
amount of television broadcast for
example has that helped
general understanding between players
might have to drop something
we're doing great today
what else can we drop i mean well
there's been a trade of pawns on the
board
but still the status quo maintained i
think it's almost against me because i
noticed that every time someone asked me
a question here you're pushing something
over but but to answer the question
quickly it's um i think it's a whole lot
easier for a chess player to become good
at other mind games than it is for
players who's played other games to
become a good chess player it's it's
just something about
that instinctive feel and something that
you have to you have to grow up with it
to not reach the ceiling too early i
think there's there's a lot of cases of
chess players moving on to poker for
example i mean we saw magnus carlsen
recently playing a big event and
i i know chris chuck he's won millions
other players you know there's lots of
cases of that transition
as well but we do have a lot of moves in
the game here david change and pawn
structure and how's how are things sort
of
going here we can just show the last
couple of moves um
white did actually try to challenge
black's strong pawn center here um so he
pushed forward with his own pawn two
squares and when you push forward with
your pawn two squares if your opponent
has a pawn ready to capture then on
passant is possible and that's actually
happened so anish giri took this pawn as
if it just moved one square and uh after
white recaptured as you mentioned simon
a change in pawn structure and
at least temporarily there is a pawn up
for grabs in the center of the board
because this white bishop has been
blocked in black can go greedy and grab
white central pawn but i'm not sure he
wants to rush with this because after a
trade for example white's queen just
moving out the way suddenly there's a
lot of pressure black pieces which are
nicely centralized they are a bit clumsy
and uh white has simple ideas for
example of bringing the rook to the
center uh kind of pinning a pawn against
the black queen also there's tension on
this diagonal so white could at some
point push his pawn forward undermine
black's central pawn so yes black's a
porno but i think black loses too much
time in the process so
just instinctively i would spend
probably most of my time calculating
this move because you can win a pawn but
if you don't see maybe a follow-up if
you don't see what to do next how to
reply to white's active moves then you
can look for alternatives and black has
alternatives you can move the queen one
square forward you can just maintain the
tension there you could think about
pushing this pawn forward to try and uh
kind of push down the board and
undermine white's bishop i have no doubt
that this is what magnus would do um
just we've seen enough of his games to
know magnus loves pushing his rooks
pawns um especially on the queen side
actually on this left half of the board
just for example if this pawn pushes
forward if white tries to get rid of it
then suddenly there are threats against
this bishop and suddenly white's
position very very loose
so lots of choice for black i don't
think however that any should get greedy
should get tempted and take this pawn i
think greed is not good in this
situation
and uh thinking for a while anish he's
probably calculating that move yeah
yeah i mean this is
a complex middle game now and the other
thing i think the reason they need to
spend more time here they're not
familiar with the position um because
often when you learn an opening uh at a
lot of levels you get used to what the
opening leads to the middle game
structure but as the opening was very
unique here they've got challenges they
might not be as used to
a unique position yeah and it's also a
kind of unique pawn sacrifice i mean
certainly not something that we see on
every day chess
and well critical moment for anish and
uh whilst the players are pausing for
thought i do have to share with you a
quite funny answer from john hickman um
who says you know our quiz of the day is
what is your chest level
he says that his chest level is chess
tourist as it's great to travel to
different places to play chess and i'm
in good company as that's how gary
kasparov has referred to himself as in a
tournament in retirement in retirement
well that's a very interesting story
wasn't there gary kasparov when he was
playing and when he was the world
champion um he played in one competition
i don't know where one of the players
i think it was serbia one of the players
in that competition was like world
number 10 or something 27 30 or 50
rating and uh gary just said he's just
the chess tourists you know he's very
very rude about this guy rude and then
and then
and then he kind of later beat that guy
and then he kind of came up with this
terrible analogy should i say it yeah of
course yeah we want to hear it yeah yeah
definitely he said he used some opening
opening novelty of his and he said it
was like using a machine gun to swap
flight i think it was a nuclear it was
like using a nuclear missile to destroy
a fly
this is like i wasted this i wasted this
opening novelty on this fly why did i
bother you know i could it's like using
a nuclear missile to destroy a fly and
it's like i thought blue you know you
also didn't like the guy much but i i
won't mention the guy's name he's really
she's a really strong player you know
very like good 20 i think 2700. i think
he was 27 at least 30 at the time when
it was you know really really you know
strong ratings so but that was kind of i
guess gary like you know showing his
power and you know showing he's the king
of the animal kingdom you know top of
the food chain there so definitely gone
from chess tourist destroyer to chess
tourist himself these days uh gary
caspar you know i have to say when it
comes to chess tourists i i
also just sometimes describe myself as a
chess tourist because i have on occasion
and again i'm not sure well i should be
telling everyone this but i have chosen
tournaments based on how good the food
that they're serving yes
i literally paid one because they served
amazing cake
meanwhile one of the moves we mentioned
and we showed this position a few
moments ago we'll dig deeper in a moment
yeah a little curious about when it
comes to jordan van forest here because
he's i remember when he broke through
when he won in the netherlands and he
really emerged on the top scene he was
known as pretty much this
opening theorist he
got himself into long long opening
variations but he didn't expect much
from his middle game that's changed now
hasn't it that's definitely changed i
think that always changes when you're a
player when you mature
i think i mean now i'm a bit older as
well i definitely tried to steer the
game straight to the middle game i try
to avoid any opening debate because
that's where things can go wrong that's
where the kind of variance is at its
highest in the opening if you've missed
one thing if your opponent's computer is
a bit stronger if they've dug a bit
deeper then you could get wiped out in
the opening so um anish jordan both
opening specialists but they definitely
in this game at least they've taken the
battle straight to the middle game and
yeah as we mentioned it is livening up
it is a bit more complicated now and a
bit more forcing perhaps so
just to rewind black did push this pawn
forward this is one of the moves i
highlighted and
white captured this pawn that pawn was
just too much of a nuisance now i'm
expecting a niche uh okay now he grabs
the pawn interesting um i thought he
would just bring his rook across first
and undermine this bishop at least force
white onto the defensive for a move or
two and then consider what to do about
the pawn structure but uh no he did
decide to remove this white pawn and as
we mentioned probably after a trade of
knights which i think is
uh inevitable then white just will
sidestep with this queen and steal this
dilemma for black these three pieces are
targets for the white rook this white
rook at the bottom of the board it's
blocked for now but it does have these
targets so many pieces
to look at and also this black pawn i
think
it just doesn't feel comfortable for
example if white gets another move say
black just is a bit too slow here if
white gets one more move then these two
white rooks in the center of the board
are going to do
so much damage and there we go the night
trade and okay not just the queen move
that i was expecting
he's even more direct jordan he grabs a
pawn in the center
tactics galore
exchanges galore because after this
knight disappears he has opened up this
white rook white's a piece down but now
he grabs the black knight back and uh
after a trade here i'm expecting to see
rook takes bishop
and yep a queen trade as well
everything flying off the board suddenly
the vacuum cleaner is out and in this
current position white is a pawn up but
one of those two uh one of those extra
pawns
lies on the a file and these pawns are
weak very very weak and easy targets for
the black rooks
i'm surprised you wouldn't rushed into
this i mean
i was actually not even on my radar that
knight takes pawn move but trading
things off when you've got such
weaknesses yes you might be a pawn up
temporarily but black's bishop holds
everything together
and white's bishop it takes a while for
it to become a strong piece again
yeah and also
you know from a very selfish point of
view i really like that the pattern on
the board when all nearly all of black's
minor pieces were on the e line
when you see that it's quite nice
creating patterns on the board isn't it
i mean
how could you just get rid of it
what you want to do here is clearly go
bishop f3 to e2 if david can maybe show
that you know can we do that so this
would have been the best move for
example this pattern this would have
been
this would have been the type of thing
we wanted to see but um instead we did
see everything get hoovered off and if
we do fast forward back again to the
current position
yes white is trying to activate his
bishop maybe he's trying to trade off
for blacks kind of
this black bishop is like a plug at the
moment holding everything together
but
i think the drawing margin is very high
here for anish for example he can just
move his rook move his rook forward i'm
not sure which square but uh just create
a path for his other rook to come and
gang up against these weaknesses
sometimes we talk about past pawns and
strengths but here these two pawns are
easy easy targets one of them for sure
is going to drop off
and it looks to me like it's going to be
exchange town
coming up and uh i would have thought
the bishops the works pawns
they're coming off maybe maybe
even one side might have a porn
advantage but i think the other side
will get a lot of activity in exchange
so i think i think a draw is is looking
the most likely at the moment here
certainly and okay that move has
happened so black lifting his rook up
the board creating a path doubling up
rooks is always an effective strategy
when your opponent has weaknesses uh to
target so yeah good move there from
anish he's low on the clock four minutes
but after the queens came off after
everything got traded four minutes is
plenty of time for black yeah and uh
yeah i think jordan missing an
opportunity he had nearly double
anisha's time
and he had so much tension to play with
that's where he's been successful
against anish in the past in these kind
of complicated middle games and this
position is really simple you know it's
very obvious you highlighted the plan
that anish will follow and
it just makes sense you know
what has some porn weaknesses attack
those poor weaknesses the end
and uh yeah definitely
definitely i think a bad decision from
jordan i agree
and uh
yeah i mean he's not worse he's not
losing or anything jordan but
no more winning chances i feel for white
if anything i would take black here
and i was just gonna whilst uh jordan is
thinking about what to do we have some
really good answers when we come into
this really simple question what is your
chest level
and everyone at home is coming up with
these awesome answers jerry graham
uh organizer of uh
he says that quite possibly the best
chess tournament in the world
he paid me to say that but no no it's a
great tournament in ireland
he says my chest level is more like pub
level chess
because i don't seem to play anywhere
else
very drunk and pub level chess i'd say
as well
um that's a good level good it's a good
friendly level right you know you have
the most chess uh fun sorry when you
know you're sat there with your friends
yeah well enjoying it it's quite
interesting because um bamrati is a
tournament in ireland it was cancelled
this year um and it it's really drawn in
some great players in the past like we
mentioned peter svidler other players
wesley soh because it's in ireland it's
very friendly tournament but this year
we surprised him actually by going over
there and streaming from the pub so it's
an online tournament instead so he took
our computers into the pub in ireland
and uh just met jerry there in the pub
so it was yes it was a pub tournament in
over in bombaretti you know so it was
very nice good fun so uh back to the
game and i don't think much is changing
really here is it david so far i don't
know i'm very surprised every move from
jordan i just can't guess it um i've
played it many times and that's always
the case i can never guess jordan van
pers moves and uh if we jump to the
current position as you mentioned simon
nothing will happen we're heading
towards the draw if the bishops come off
if black for example plays bishop takes
bishop the white rook recaptures
everything's just going to get traded
off black will win his pawn back here
but in the meantime white rook is going
to go hunting for pawns as well and
yeah everything will get traded rooks
pawns it's going to be a draw i think if
anish wants to win then there is an
option of pushing his pawn forward it's
a bit risky um the black bishop is now a
bit loose is temporarily defended by the
black rook but wherever the white bishop
goes now for example if it steps back
okay he does trade the bishops i was
going to say now the black king can
start centralizing itself
i would be very tempted to start pushing
these this majority black has four pawns
on this side of the board against three
he could have pushed and tried to win
but what about this move and another
move that might be surprising jordan's
jordan's going for the ugliest pawn
structure award i think he's winning
that award
doubled isolated pawns here an isolated
pawn here doubled isolated pawns and
another hang on a second didn't he lose
yes yesterday against the way were you
with these two double well two sets of
double pawns that's true and actually
yesterday against wei yi with colours
reversed he had exactly this structure
and he ended up losing and it was a
double rook end game so
jordan he's not learning from past
mistakes maybe it's fine here i guess he
wants to keep his rook in the center
attacking this uh kind of backwards
blacks but i don't think i could play
that move even if it's the best move i
just don't think i could bring myself to
taking and doubling another set of pawns
you know it's just visually like yeah
you know it just makes me feel a bit
nauseous you know i just couldn't do it
i i mean just i don't know would you
guys the thing is though there's
terrible terrible pawns i mean just
imagine if the black king you look look
at her it's coming forward and uh give
it two more moves and it might make its
way over to the f5 square and start like
nibbling on some pawns later one day
yeah
easy path towards the weaknesses i think
temporarily though white should be fine
white needs to go active with his
remaining rooks this is a good lesson
for everyone if you have long term
weaknesses like bad pawns go active with
your pieces play for the short term play
dynamically energetically and white's
rook has to come up the board now i feel
just to attack and kind of team up
against black's weaknesses so
jordan is not worse he's not losing but
ugly strange decisions from him
yeah i'm just having a bit of a glance
on the
evaluation on the other games here and
it seems like it's a very dry start
today um except for viewedit who's
getting a really strong start against
shanklin with black pieces it seems like
everything is quite equal at least
evaluation-wise yeah maybe they're just
warming up and you called it moving day
earlier
and for me that's a new phrase but
that's a golf reference by the way the
third day of a four-day tournament is
always the moving day because that's
when you position yourself in the tables
and then you get ready for the final day
i thought you thought about moving flats
and i was like
what do i miss
but uh yeah moving day and maybe it's
just the nerves they know this is the
calm before the storm i mean the next
few games players are going to need to
take big risks to try and win to try and
position themselves in the top eight and
another move that we can predict there
sorry i just again this is every jordan
move is unpredictable at the moment why
put the rook there when we could go to
the seventh just why
i mean brooks on the seventh are
supposed to be well they are good going
dating back to nimzovich who pointed
that out and uh in a rook ending you put
your rooks on the most active square
what why why why put it there i mean i
think he's still okay but i still you
know just don't quite understand
yeah but you know yeah i think he is
still okay for now but he needs to start
playing some really accurate moves
because if things go wrong those uh that
really bad pawn structure is going to
come and well just
benefit a niche yeah it's the trend as
well it's it's not just one big blunder
which i we haven't seen from either
player so far but it's just a series of
small strange maybe strategic
mistakes from jordan which may
eventually add up to something bigger
and uh here we go black's remaining rook
the only piece that wasn't participating
for black it's found an open file it has
squares to jump into in white's half it
has targets as we've seen with all of
the weak white pawns
do you think it's enough to push for a
win anish is definitely the one playing
for the win here um i think even if
everything goes wrong for anish he
should still be able to draw this game
but if things go wrong for jordan all of
white's pawns are dropping off so um the
yes it's equal according to the computer
at least or roughly equal but the margin
for error i mean it's tiny now for
jordan i mean for instance i really like
anish's last move you know after all
jordan voluntarily gave up his control
of the open line put a rook there but
i'm thinking that rook can go to the
beautiful sixth row
and uh start looking at uh
love it when that happens it's like
bingo yeah i got it right it never
happens to me so just enjoy it yeah
just enjoy it while it's there you know
but yeah it's a great idea if anchor and
the idea is you just want to use that
rook and attack right yeah just there's
nothing sophisticated about that move
yeah and uh simple plan you want to go
after white's pawns white can start
attacking black's pawns black only has
really one weakness uh but this can be
easily defended for example if the white
rook steps across black can just step
his own rook up the board and kind of
lock things down defend this pawn and
steal the same idea at some point maybe
of the black rook coming across um yeah
or maybe even here the black rook steps
up to the the fifth rank and again ideas
of going after wheat pawns later in the
game still should be a draw with best
play um let's get that straight but it's
all about anish geary now and whether he
can probe whether he can look for
weaknesses and maybe make jordan a bit
nervous the longer you have pawns like
this the more nervous you get uh i think
jordan would love to just kind of offer
shake hands get out of this game with a
draw but uh anish despite his clock time
despite having less time on the uh
despite being under two minutes now he
will want to kind of get a better i have
to say guys as well i mean i don't
normally do this but i had to look at
our friends game uh gwen jones against
the world champion and what on earth is
going on there we're getting we get a
chance to have a look at this after this
game guaranteed would definitely have a
look at this game but that is
absolutely mad and it looks like a
dragon
opening to me which is uh but we will
come back to i'm sure because that that
is just i i don't know what's happening
there pieces have been thrown on the
board randomly by looks of it it's in my
eyes see yeah and the game between jones
and carson it definitely looks like
someone has just kind of
done a lucky dip just throwing pieces on
and just seen where they fall yeah
that's right so
i've just been looking at their
evaluations and they've been kind of
going mad at times as well yeah but
sometimes the evaluation bar can't be
trusted because like going back to that
game of gawain jones against magnus
carlsen
it's crazy but the evaluation evaluation
bar is like
middle just saying draw yeah just saying
it's equal 0.00 you know all is good and
another shocking move here from jordan
he's just given up one of his pawns
don't get it never guess this i
understand sacrificing pawns in the
opening middle game to gain time to gain
squares gain activity for your pieces
but in an end game pawns are everything
why can't black just take this pawn take
it i i i it's been impossible to predict
his moves i mean why are you first of
all giving yourself that poor weakness
then why are you giving up the pawn that
pawn could be back in front of the king
you could have the same position here
but that white pawn which has just been
moved could be one square in front of
the king what why why play like this i
mean it seems it seems rather suicidal
to me this i guess his idea is to go on
the attack in an end game but after
black's pawn captures the white pawn i
guess he wants to swing across and now
black does have a target over here
the black king can defend it but now
maybe he wants to swing his other rook
up the board he wants to lift his rook
across and start going for the black
king but somehow it feels a bit
superficial it feels as if for example
black can just push a pawn forward
suddenly actually these three pawns are
really launching forward and black can
maybe worse comes the worst hide the
king in the corner maybe black and hide
the other way as well because the black
rook guards this pawn
okay uh we're bound to see something
like this because this is the current
position black's king did indeed step
forward and white's rook
doing the same i'm not a big fan of
venetian's uh king move actually because
yeah it kind of the line that you showed
made perfect sense hide the king on the
first row
sorry the eighth row and then have the
two rooks horizontally defend their
pawns but here
you know maybe there's a little bit of
danger
actually there's a lot of danger what
are we talking about you know the rook
check is actually quite
really weird square to move king ivanka
i agree i mean why why not try to keep
it safe and is he really going to try to
go passive but he can't he can't go
behind the pawn can he no he can't and
that h the pawn on h6 is also vulnerable
to attack
and he you know when you were going why
why why it just reminded me of like that
record why why
i was
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah i mean meanwhile stranger decisions
from both sides but one thing we have to
focus on is that anish giri is under 30
seconds i think
if he had more time he would have
actually found a better path in the last
few moves
and uh maybe that clock situation will
stop him from winning this game uh do
you believe that jordan got himself in
trouble here with poor offensive choices
or poor defensive choices it's a bit of
both i think when he should have been
defensive he tried to be a bit too
offensive
and yeah i think in end games especially
that's one area that i mean you can't
really play
kind of hard and fast with the rules you
have to just play the position
if you've got weak pawns defend them
just lock things down hold the line um
you can't just give away pawns throw
things forward kind of make things
happen when there's nothing there's no
actual energy behind your pieces there's
just not enough material left on the
board so um it's surprising to me that
he's trying to go active in a position
where he didn't need to do anything but
it is his style and it's brought him a
long way in the chess world and
i think when he masters that in the end
game at least kind of when to go on the
attack when to just sit i think he's
going to be kind of a top 10 fixture for
years
but is that also one of the problems for
geary the fact that he's unable to win
as many games as he should be based on
his positions
yes and i think anish he's uh he loves
control
and
against jordan you never get control
that's one thing
so
yeah if anish doesn't win this one i
think he's going to be kicking himself
yeah they are like opposites aren't they
i mean it does seem that way aneesh he
does love control and jordan loves
losing control it seems you know
the ice jordan's the fire yeah that's
right yeah yeah it's true and it's very
interesting clash of styles yeah it's
another thing i love about i love about
chess and again we're talking about
poker and you probably get this in poker
just the different styles i mean maybe
one's not better than the other
in chess you get that a lot that you
know people show their personality on
the board um which is yeah i think that
goes for a lot of mind games one style
is not necessarily better but one player
will always be better in long run yeah
yeah no i mean you just reminded me of
this little fable i heard this morning
about the scorpion and the frog have you
guys heard of it
nope no i think so on the back of the
yeah that's right yeah
yeah like uh
the scorpion asks the frog
hey you know can you give me a lift and
uh on your back and uh take me across
the water and the frog is no no no no no
no no you're gonna sting me and you know
it's bad things are gonna happen the
scorpion's gonna go scorpion said of
course don't be stupid that will never
happen i mean that wouldn't be
beneficial for both of us
and
if we see a porn move and
yeah of course they swim across the
thing and of course the scorpion stings
the frog they're both drowning and the
frog asks why and he goes well i'm
scorpion it's in my nature
you've been looking for that h-bomb for
a while david it suddenly arrived
exactly and uh i know that simon perked
up right there as soon as harry the
h-born live no i would i was listening
to vancouver's story i was thinking
about i was thinking about beatboxing in
the background
yeah with a score but you don't know
okay okay suddenly things are really
lightening up and suddenly it's a three
result game again i was saying that
things were going in black's favor but
black has lost control and he reads lost
control and we know he likes that
control um let's jump in in the current
position white's rook is actually under
attack from this black pawn but when it
moves i'm not sure exactly where it
wants to go to be honest it can go up
the board
for example this white rook it can just
slide across but no matter where it goes
white has this huge card up his sleeve
now this white pawn for example if the
black rook kind of gets greedy white's
porn is only three squares away from
promotion now and it's a race black's
king is actually on the wrong side
black's king would love to be on the
other side of its own pawn here just so
that it can kind of stop harry from
running but harry has two supporters the
two white rooks
and even if black goes active in a
situation like this why can just defend
still very very tricky for black to stop
this guy from running
strange game isn't it that's really
absurd i i think you can tell that you
know they they know each other very well
they're obviously when you're playing
some from the same country there's a
little bit more at stake because you you
play in the national team you are
probably more friendly with them or you
know them better at least so it seems
nervous game distance yes certainly and
when you're talking about nerves anish
only has 15 seconds on the clock and
that's why he played a safety first move
retreated the rook to the eighth row
just to keep an eye on that uh rogue
harry the h pawn and
yeah i mean
it's i mean you said that they know each
other really well but uh for a long time
jordan was working with a niche
yeah and uh it was really interesting we
recorded a couple of podcasts one with a
niche one with jordan and
there's a bit of tension there maybe and
they both admitted to it because jordan
did work with anish and moving on to
work with magnus of course there's some
rivalry there's debate about what
opening ideas are secret um kind of
sharing knowledge is always difficult
but okay meanwhile black is going active
with his king but
why did he give up this pawn panic is
here
sorry ivanka i was going to say panic
you know because he's threatening
me it's a brilliant idea wow i've got to
show this one okay aneesh has such a
sneaky idea in mind i was wondering why
he gave up a pawn but now if white is
careless and for example just does a
nothing move then suddenly black is
going to play rook takes pawn and this
wins sacrificing a rook kind of tricking
the white king into coming forward and
then bang the king is trapped on the
side of the board
simply no escape squares the uh the
black king and the two black pawns
actually cut off all the skate squares
for this white king so in the current
position this is a winning threat for an
ishgiri rook takes pawn
how does he stop this suddenly the black
the white king maybe has to just run
away at some point and just run away
back to safety before it's too late as
well if the black rook comes across and
cuts off the white king's escape route
it's game over suddenly jordan with 25
seconds he needs to either run away with
his king or maybe go active with his own
rook just to start kind of the counter
attack against black's king maybe bring
the rook across uh after rook takes pawn
running away with his own king that is
the key oh i don't know about this move
he's played he's played his rook over
but
this wins for black now and there we go
the evaluation bar okay not even that
he's trapped the white rook oh
let's go back to the players because
what a trick
the white rook is suddenly trapped it
has no squares to go to oh and she's
about to take the win we saw jordan kind
of cover his face for a second and
there we go do we have a result
one move
it all turns around and anish wins